Trump's indictment means that the
American Empire is guaranteed to
collapse but not for the reason you
think it is think about it in super
corrupt third world countries if you're
in power and you have an annoying
political opponent that is threatening
your position what do you do you slap
him with some trumped up charges and
send him to prison boom problem solved
and that's exactly what's Happening Here
Pandora's Box has been opened and now
Republicans are going to start trying to
send Democrats to jail Democrats will
try to send more Republicans to jail and
it's just going to be a never-ending
spiral of political destabilization and
guess who's taking advantage of this
crisis China while the American public
has been distracted by this China has
been quietly unifying our enemies and
getting them to ditch the dollar and you
don't hear a word about it in the
mainstream media which is why